.
>>> A WASHINGTON FAMILY GRIEVING
THE LOSS OF PATRICK LANE, A
FATHER OF TWO WHO RECENTLY DIED
OF COVID AT THE AGE OF 45.
HE WAS NOT VACCINATED.
PATRICK LANE'S CHILDREN JOIN ME,
KATIE AND EVAN LANE.
GUYS, I'M SO SORRY FOR THE LOSS
OF YOUR FATHER.
IT'S SUCH A TRAGEDY AND I KNOW
IT'S BEEN HARD ON BOTH OF YOU
AND KATIE, HE JUST MOVED YOU
INTO COLLEGE LIKE A MONTH AGO,
RIGHT?
>> YES, IT WAS ONE MONTH AGO
THAT HE WAS COMPLETELY HEALTHY,
HELPING ME MOVE ALL MY FURNITURE
INTO MY FIRST APARTMENT, DOING
ALL THE HEAVY LIFTING FOR ME.
>> HE MOVED YOU IN, THIS IS YOUR
FIRST APARTMENT AT COLLEGE, I
MIGHT ADD.
HE MOVED YOU IN THERE, HE STAYED
THE NIGHT WITH YOU AND WHAT DID
HE SAY TO YOU AS HE WAS LEAVING?
>> HE GAVE ME A REALLY BIG HUG
AND HE SAID "I'M PROUD OF YOU,
KATIE BUG."
HE WALKED OUT MY FRONT DOOR, AND
IF I HAD KNOWN THAT THAT WAS
GOING TO BE MY LAST TIME SEEING
MY DAD IN PERSON ALIVE AND WELL,
I DON'T THINK I WOULD HAVE LET
GO OF HIM.
>> WHY WAS HE SO HESITANT TO GET
VACCINATED, KATIE?
>> THERE'S MULTIPLE REASONS, I
THINK.
ONE OF WHICH WAS SOME OF THE
MEDIA THAT HE INGESTED.
HE WASN'T BY ANY MEANS FAR
RIGHT.
HE WAS RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE, AND
HE CONSUMED MEDIA FROM BOTH
SIDES, AND JUST SOME OF THE
MISINFORMATION ON ONE OF THOSE
SIDES MADE HIM HESITANT.
SO HE WAS GOING TO WAIT FOR FDA
APPROVAL, BUT BY THE TIME THAT
PFIZER HAD BEEN APPROVED, IT WAS
ALREADY TOO LATE.
>> PFIZER GOT THE FULL FDA
APPROVAL AND YOUR FATHER WAS
ALREADY SICK.
EVAN, TALK TO ME ABOUT YOUR
FINAL GOOD-BYE TO YOUR FATHER.
DID YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO SPEND
ANY REAL TIME WITH HIM?
>> NOT REALLY.
I WAS ALREADY STAYING AT ANOTHER
HOUSE, AND HE WAS JUST COMING BY
TO PICK SOMETHING UP AND HE
DIDN'T WANT TO GET TOO CLOSE
BECAUSE HE WAS TOO WORRIED ABOUT
GETTING ME SICK SO I DIDN'T EVEN
GET TO HUG HIM BEFORE HE LEFT,
AND THEN BEFORE I KNEW IT, HE
WAS GONE.
>> YOU GUYS ARE VACCINATED NOW,
EVAN.
WHAT WAS THE MESSAGE ULTIMATELY
THAT YOUR FATHER WANTED TO
SPREAD ABOUT VACCINES?
>> HE WASN'T ANTI-VACCINE.
HE WAS JUST HESITANT AND NOW
THAT, YOU KNOW, PFIZER HAS BEEN
FDA APPROVED, I DON'T THINK HE
WOULD HAVE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
TELLING PEOPLE TO GET THAT
VACCINE.
>> HIS FINAL WORDS TO MY STEPMOM
ON A FACETIME CALL WAS THAT HE
WISHES, HE WISHED THAT HE WAS
VACCINATED.
>> THOSE WERE HIS FINAL WORDS?
>> TO MY STEPMOM, THE LAST CALL
THAT SHE HAD WITH HIM, HE SAID
THAT HE WISHED THAT HE WAS
VACCINATED.
>> KATIE, YOU SAID FROM ONE
MEDIA SOURCE IN PARTICULAR HE
WAS GETTING MISINFORMATION -- HE
WAS GETTING INFORMATION THAT LED
HIM TO BE HESITANT ON VACCINES.
WHO?
WHO WAS HE LISTENING TO?
>> HE WATCHED SOME TUCKER
CARLSON VIDEOS ON YOUTUBE, AND
SOME OF THOSE VIDEOS INVOLVED
SOME MISINFORMATION ABOUT
VACCINES, AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT PLAYED A ROLE.
>> EVAN, WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE
TO REMEMBER ABOUT YOUR DAD?
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO REMEMBER
HIM?
>> I'M ALWAYS GOING TO REMEMBER
HIM AS JUST THE FUN DAD IN ANY
SCHOOL GATHERING, OR JUST THE
PERSON WHO ALWAYS TRIES TO BRING
EVERYONE'S MOOD UP, IF THEY'RE
FEELING DOWN.
>> I'M LOOKING AT PICTURES RIGHT
NOW ON THE SCREEN.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE THEM
BUT HIS SMILE JUST BURSTS RIGHT
THROUGH THE SCREEN RIGHT THERE.
HE JUST LOOKS LIKE THERE WAS SO
MUCH JOY.
>> YES.
>> A JOY, AND A LOT OF LIFE
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO LIVE.
>> KATIE AND EVAN LANE, LISTEN,
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
RIGHT NOW, AND YOU KNOW, YOU'R